hola hola if them we're in Frankfort of
mine medium whatcha gonna say we've come
to discover this city's a european
economic center with a long history and
huge contrasts between that history and
its skyscrapers a student could come
with us let's go
ah like I said on the house where Goethe
was born like us the goethe museum here
at last Funaki
Emmaline less dead and i read many of
his books since my childhood now it's
lovely to be here where he wrote them to
go through the same rooms and stand in
front of the same walls is a very moving
facetious Elohim oficios esta en de Lima
Peru days SS komui mobilize adore
Gustav Paris are real men day so I can't
describe how I feel I got some sue it's
incredible to stand in this room where
he was born see us if you have to
experience they weren't gonna sell
no case in Bray a mimosa mimosa damania
every time we come to Germany we love
coming to this fantastic old town centre
de cuyo really has a unique beauty una
vez esta muy particula unica
wow wow what an impressive view
the duckies from here you can see all
the office towers and banks yeppers and
despite that Frankfort maintains its old
buildings which are important for the
character of the country pero no para un
poco lo que la cultura del pais semi
Clara men television and from here you
can clearly see the division of
Frankfort into two parts it's great to
watch the ships from the banks of the
river mine
oh my dad look one of the typical apples
that show we're in the cider district
let's see the ready yes a typical German
tavern let's try a regional meal I'm
starving
is this a cider jug a bemble lender
shopper shopper sure sure sure 70 that
epi would happen everywhere the shrine
axis oh thank you sure on the lip-sync
accredit danke
when I find out at the mouth okay after
drinking Ebel boy from a bemble and
eating this delicious meal will say good
bye bye bye I hope you come and try this
because it's marvelous choose